Joe Biden has announced we will respond
to a drone strike that killed three US
soldiers and injured 34 more they say it
was done by iran-backed militia groups
and came from Syria we're now getting a
breaking report from Sky News that as
early as tonight Joe Biden May authorize
military action in the Middle East which
could spark World War II and I'm the
only one who saying it World War II has
been trending for some time especially
after these three US soldiers had been
killed and there are numerous reports
coming out about the fears escalating
and of course kind of feels like beating
a dead horse but you have many world
leaders saying over and over again over
the past year that we are knocking on
the doors of World War II in fact many
said we are already in it we just don't
know it yet so we'll see I suppose with
all the news now coming out about the
fears of World War III there's a lot to
actually break down but we got big news
on the border everybody's waiting for an
update on what happened with Biden the
Biden Administration and Texas the
National Guard the boorder of Patrol has
sided with Texas